hey this is uh this is starting to now
become
very very obvious in terms of the
concern the panic that donald trump has
about the truth getting out as to what
he was up to and who he was meeting with
in the days leading up to the trump
riots we've known now for a little while
that donald trump is doing everything he
can
to get joe biden to assert executive
privilege over
documents related to his actions leading
up to the trump riots and so far joe
biden has said he's not going to do that
we now have learned thanks to some
really great reporting from cnn crime
and justice reporter caitlin polance
that donald trump is acting desperately
to hide his daily schedule in the days
leading up to the january 6th riot why
would he want to do that well
we can infer
that if it became known what he was up
to and who he was meeting with there
would be a lot of overlap with people
that played roles in ginning up and
inciting the january six riots maybe
even worse maybe even worse so let's go
first to this was uh this is based on
reporting by caitlin pollants which
we'll get to cnn reporter caitlin
collins tweeted about this saying quote
major news overnight per a sworn
declaration from the national archives
trump is trying to keep more than 700
pages of files out of the hands of the
january 6th committee including 30 pages
of his daily schedule visitor logs and
call records for trump pence caitlyn
poland's reports this includes documents
from trump's top aides including three
handwritten notes from mark meadows
proposed talking points for kaylee
mcinanny files from stephen miller and
deputy council pat philbin the white
house daily diary and drafts of remarks
regarding the national archives says
trump's wants to says trump wants to
assert executive oh sorry for remarks
regarding january 6 the national archive
says trump wants to assert privilege
over a handwritten note from former
chief of staff mark meadows files
listing potential or scheduled briefings
and telephone calls concerning the
january 6th certification and other
election issues
trump doesn't want it to be known
who he was talking to about how to block
the certification on january 6th and we
have you know some pretty sensible
guesses as to why the report from cnn's
caitlyn paul and worth reading in full
um specifics it says specifics about
former president trump's efforts to keep
secret the support from his white house
for overturning his loss of the 2020
election were revealed in late night
court filings detailing more than 700
pages of handwritten notes draft
documents and daily logs related to
january 6th this is the first time for
the first time a sworn declaration of
what trump wants to keep secret
uh the records show trump wants to keep
secret include handwritten memos from
his chief of staff
call logs of trump and pence and white
house visitor records additional court
records revealed early saturday morning
trump's court case is a crucial and
potentially historic legal fight over
the authority of a former president to
protect his term in office the house's
subpoena power and the reach of
executive privilege but it's not only
that it's also an attempt for us not to
know the degree to which donald trump
was involved in planning and had four
knowledge of what ultimately took place
on january 6th the trump riots what
would his schedule expose well it's
speculation at this point because we
only know the gist of what he wants to
cover up not the content because so far
it's not been made public but maybe
there were too many meetings with people
involved or suspected to be involved in
the trump riots maybe trump actually had
phone calls with some of the people that
organized and carried out violence we
just don't know and i'm conceding that
this is speculation but this is not the
behavior of an innocent person now hold
on a second
hold on a second
i'm not saying trump doesn't deserve due
process
i'm not saying anything about that
people are innocent until proven guilty
in a court of law and it doesn't mean
that trump is guilty so everybody relax
i know that the um uh i
there's a contingent where every time i
say this is not the behavior of an
innocent person someone writes and says
david that ignores due process people
aren't guilty in the u.s until proven
innocent this isn't a court of law this
is my show and it is my opinion
colloquially that this is not the
behavior of an innocent person that
doesn't mean he's guilty of anything in
a in in a criminal trial it's not what
i'm saying he's not even been charged
the one other thought about this trump
seems to sort of be telling the january
6th committee exactly where to look for
the most relevant evidence about his
behavior
by making it clear what it is he doesn't
want revealed
last thing all of this relates to the
release of these in these documents
to the january 6th committee
if they are released to the january 6
committee there is no guarantee that
they will actually be made public to us
they may leak of course that that that's
always a a risk but this is not about
making these documents public this is
about making them available to the
january 6th committee
what do you believe
is in trump's schedule and call logs
that he wants to cover up let me know
we'll have more on this on our instagram
which you can find at david pakman show
one of our sponsors is all form hands
down the easiest way to custom build
your own sofa you choose the premium
fabric you want you choose the sofa size
shape color even the color of the legs
you can customize every aspect of your
new sofa to make sure it's the perfect
fit for your home i got my first
all-form sofa a year ago i just got a
second one which is really exciting
these really are the sofas i would have
bought for my home even if all form was
not a sponsor you really can't beat the
quality the modern minimal design the
sofas are spill stain and scratch proof
you can buy one piece and start with
that and then buy more seats and
accessories to add on later shipping is
fast and free you get a hundred days to
decide if you want to keep the sofa it
comes with a forever warranty and you'll
get 20 percent off when you go to all
form.com pacman the link is right
underneath this video